c'est que les projets pharaoniques ont
été faits qu'il ya eu un avertissement
de la chambre régionale des comptes
avant que la piscine se construisent en
disant attention vous allez grévé le les
finances de la ville pendant longtemps
vous hypothéquer l'avenir
non d'abord c'est à la xoom régionales
oui bah oui c'est la chambre et la nuit
et vous avez cité de l'expo de l'expo
aussi de l'expo qui était gentry suivra
d'accord sur l'analyse bas aux avants 1
sur la jambe régionales a averti avant
que le projet ne se montait malgré tout
vous avez impérativement aller à votre
épée ce qui a fait exploser
l'endettement
l'endettement de la donne n ya rien
rajouté 2016
la conversion veine entière était déjà
très dégradées nier vous l'avez encore
plus dégradée en entrant sur en étant le
dire en susurrant des camps l'aller les
finances de l'agglomération jean
baptiste gagne ou avez vous mal géré la
ville
non moi je voudrais parler
d'attractivité ce que c'était ça le
sujet et j'ai deux choses à dire sur le
sujet mais répondait d'abord sur la
situation financière s'il vous plaît on
y va on était là dessus et après je vous
donne la parole sur l'attractivité de la
gestion financière de la ville l'agglo
reste de l'agglomération c'est une
gestion saine et la meilleure façon de
le constater ces deux choses d'abord que
la capacité de désendettement qu'est le
baromètre de toutes les collectivités et
dans tous les débats municipaux vous en
parler aujourd'hui il faut cinq années
et demie pour et bien désendetter
l'agglomération 6 ennemis pour la ville
pas vrai et bien alors la saisie 6,16 m
pour la même opération non 30 et 31
décembre 2010 9,7 ce chiffre qui se
disant on est dans le sud je lis gilles
en reste mais à 12 ans on est envoyé en
italie ou êtes capable à 32 millions
pour parler de cette finance rangueil
la chambre régionale des comptes comme
hicham daoudi était adjoint aux finances
de la ville a décidé de mettre sous
surveillance notre ville parce que
l'endettement avait trop augmenté à la
ville de dole alors sa série gt gt en
mars jusqu'en avril 2014
jamais la chambre régionale des comptes
mais il eut me dire ça on ne met jamais
la coiffure on avait invité document